KORY JEFFREY:
Welcome, everybody.
We are on site today at
Founder World in San Francisco.
Joining me in the studio
is Monica Phillips
from Spark Plug Labs.
She's a motivational speaker
and a leadership coach.
Thank you for joining me.
MONICA PHILLIPS: Thank
you for having me.
KORY JEFFREY: Yeah.
So let's start with
Spark Plug Labs.
Tell me about that.
MONICA PHILLIPS: I
started my business
two years ago after coaching
and leading marketing
and development for 18 years.
And I woke up one day, and I
knew there was something more
for me.
And I really wanted to
help people every day.
And so I started Spark Plug
Labs as a coaching philosophy
to help people move from
inspiration to action.
And I work with a lot of
start ups and tech founders.
And I find that so often,
we are our own hindrance
in the way of our success.
And we have these paths
and these journeys,
and we have this
saboteur-- that voice
on the side of our
shoulder that says,
oh, you said you
wanted to do that,
but you don't really
want to do that.
It would be too much work.
And I work with people around
habits, accountability,
challenges, values,
articulation--
so that everyone can lead
a really fulfilling life.
And unapologetically take
breaks and reward themselves
and enjoy every step of the way.
And sometimes it is hard.
KORY JEFFREY: So let's
start at the 10,000 feet.
What is the difference in the
philosophy for Spark Plug Labs
as opposed to anything else?
MONICA PHILLIPS:
So my philosophy
is do something everyday that
matters, set great habits,
lead a thrilling life, and
you will hit your goals.
And it's what we do and how
we show up that matters.
And it is always showing
up and keeping your focus.
So I was on a panel
with Sami Inkinen once,
and he said don't do 90% of
the things that you're doing.
And I love that.
I think it is so true.
So much of what we do,
we don't need to do.
We could be doing
the top 2% of it.
So a lot of people
I work with who
are stuck because
they're doing too much,
and they can't get the
right things done-- we
look at what is they're doing.
Let's write down everything
you have to do, and then
take away everything that you
could delegate to someone else.
And delegate it.
And what is your core list?
What are the three things
you have to do this week?
And honestly, when we have
more than three to five things
on our list, we get stuck
because there's so much,
we don't know where to begin.
KORY JEFFREY: So we talked a
little bit about habit forming,
and you're talking a little
bit about list making.
How does one go about
forming good habits?
MONICA PHILLIPS: So one
of my favorite examples
that I will give for
myself lately-- I
was bombarded with paperwork.
And I run my own business,
and I have to file taxes,
and I can't even get
it to my accountant
because it would make
no sense to anyone.
It was a mess.
And actually the
biggest limitation
was just making a decision.
There were so many options
that were available.
I finally decided on
Shoeboxed and Xero.
And Shoeboxed saved all my
receipts and business cards.
It syncs with Xero, my
online bookkeeping tool,
and I can send that
to any accountant.
And they can make sense of
this chaos that I once had.
Overnight, I created a habit.
Every time I get a receipt,
I'll take a picture of it.
I have the Shoeboxed app.
I get a receipt, I
take a picture of it,
and it automatically gets saved.
It's searchable by
location, by amount--
I can identify whether it's
reimbursable or deductible.
And I have gotten rid of
all my paper receipts.
I also mailed a bunch
of them in-- Tissue Box
which then scans them for you.
Because I had a backlog,
a drawer full of receipts.
KORY JEFFREY: Sure.
MONICA PHILLIPS: It was my
shame corner, and that's gone.
It's something like that,
where it's really easy.
It's not about the success of
the habit you want to create.
It's about the intention.
So I want to run a marathon.
OK, great.
That means tomorrow, I'm
going to run five miles.
So what do I need to do?
I need to put on
my running clothes.
So after I brush my
teeth every night,
I set my running clothes
out on the floor.
That's the intention.
When you wake up in the morning
and you see your gym clothes
on the floor, it's a lot
easier to run five miles
than if you're just waking up.
You're rolling out of bed,
you're not really sure,
maybe not.
It's nice and warm
and cozy in your bed.
It might be cold outside, or
it might be too hot outside.
What is that you're
giving yourself?
And then being OK
with not doing it.
Maybe you don't
do it one morning.
Maybe it's Sunday, and
you have brunch plans,
and you don't run
the five miles.
OK, let it go.
Don't run 10 miles the next day.
Don't make it so hard
that you can't do it.
But be OK with missing a day.
Don't miss two days,
don't miss three days,
don't miss four days.
Then it's not a habit anymore.
So something that's
really simple
where you set the intention.
You know that there's
a vision, and you know
what the success looks like.
KORY JEFFREY: So what is your
role in this when you engage?
When Spark Plug Labs
engages, what do you guys
do in that equation?
MONICA PHILLIPS: The first
need I do, is I look at values.
And I think that's something
that's sometimes is overlooked,
where we're coaching
around a specific skill.
I'm looking at the
values of a person,
and the values of a
team, and the culture.
How do people work together?
What do they want to mean?
When they wake up
in five years, what
do they want people to
say about themselves?
And then what does
that mean for me today?
Who am I being?
Am I being that person, or
am I being someone else?
And if that's what I want,
and we're working together,
and my client says one thing
and acts another way, I can say,
hey look-- you said
you wanted this.
But that's not what
you're giving yourself.
And here's where I'm
going to challenge
you to stretch yourself more.
And it could be very specific,
business growth strategies,
market strategy, team
building, leadership skills.
So I coach around all of those
soft skills of what it means
to build a great organization.
It's also how we show up
every day for ourselves.
Because if we don't
want it for ourselves,
it's a lot harder to
give that someone else.
KORY JEFFREY: Right.
MONICA PHILLIPS: I know that
it's probably an old cliche
that you have to love
yourself before you
can love someone else.
And I think that's true,
really true for start ups.
You have to really
love what you're doing,
so you can share that passion
with everyone who's around you.
KORY JEFFREY: So, and not
to paint with broad strokes,
you said you work with technical
and non-technical people,
start up people,
non-start up people,
big companies, small companies.
Is there any trends
you've seen between
the technical and nontechnical?
Are their ways that
certain types of people
get in their own way?
Is there anything
like that that you've
noticed through your career?
MONICA PHILLIPS: It's very
similar across the board, not
industry specific.
But I would say that,
with all of my clients,
the biggest
differentiator I've seen
for those who are successful
and those who maybe don't get
as far in setting the habits
and seeing real shift in terms
of what they want when they set
goals or they have big dreams
is-- I work with people
who have huge dreams.
And when you think about
coaching an executive
who's at a top-funded start up.
They are doing a lot.
KORY JEFFREY: Yeah.
MONICA PHILLIPS: What I see that
makes the most difference is
writing it down.
And that's across the board.
Writing down your goals,
writing down your strategies,
being really intentional.
And it sounds harsh sometimes.
But what I look at really
deeply is relationships.
Because we are
surrounded by technology.
Here I am talking to a
channel for Google Developers.
And at the end of the
day, it's about the person
sitting across from
you who's going
to make the difference
in that relationship.
So do you have the
right relationships?
Are you connected to people
who could introduce you
to the right relationships?
If not, where do you
find those people?
And how you set intentions
around getting those people
in your life?
KORY JEFFREY: So Founder World.
What attracts you to
an event like this?
MONICA PHILLIPS: Oh, I love
everything about this event.
I love innovation
and entrepreneurship.
I came this morning
to air my radio show
live from Founder World.
So I got to interview in
the same hour Bill Reichert,
founder of Garage
Technology Ventures,
Yvonne Cagle, a NASA astronaut.
It just-- so many interesting
people, all within an hour.
I interviewed 10
people, I think.
KORY JEFFREY: Sounds like--
MONICA PHILLIPS: You can find
it on-- yeah, yeah, I know.
It was a really great interview.
You can find it online
at SparkPlugLabs.co
and it's Powerful Conversations.
It's also in the iTunes Store.
Just fun conversations.
That's what I come for.
I come to share my passion
in wanting people to succeed.
I find that in other
parts of the country,
not everyone wants
mutual success.
And when you come
to Silicon Valley,
I find that what makes
it still really special
is that people here
want others to succeed.
And so while there's,
of course, competition--
KORY JEFFREY: Sure.
MONICA PHILLIPS: I'm
going to compete with you
and go ahead and make it better.
I would love to see that.
And it's really fun to
be surrounded by people
who are trying something new.
Not because they have
the most original idea,
but because they
want to work hard
for something that matters.
KORY JEFFREY: Obviously your
job is a lot around people,
relationships,
attitudes, behaviors.
But is there anything in
the world of tech right
now that excited you?
Is there anything?
MONICA PHILLIPS: Well, I just
went on a tour of Singularity
with my friend Pascal Finette.
And it was really
cool, and I totally
loved the virtual
reality roller coaster.
That was great.
I brought four kids with
me, my own included.
And they loved it.
We all-- the adults loved it.
I loved it.
KORY JEFFREY:
Something for everyone.
MONICA PHILLIPS: I have a
former client who runs re:3D,
the largest format 3D printer,
and is working on printing from
recycled plastic bottles.
So really making a difference
in the larger scope of things.
What I'm most
excited about here--
what I've seen a lot of on this
show-- is space exploration.
KORY JEFFREY: Yeah.
Awesome.
MONICA PHILLIPS: I got to talk
to an astronaut this morning.
And talking with
Yvonne Cagle-- what
is possible in what we're
doing here on Earth,
and what that means
for space exploration.
It's really something I have
to put my head around still.
It's kind of cool.
KORY JEFFREY: So, favorite
Google technology?
MONICA PHILLIPS:
You know, I knew
you were going to ask that.
It's a tricky one.
Like we were saying, when
technology becomes so seamless
that you don't even
know how great it is,
that's when technology's won.
And for me, it's
certainly Gmail.
My new favorite though, because
I work on the fly constantly,
is Google Sheets.
Google Docs.
Google Docs is great.
I use Google Sheets even more.
I can share data, I
can open it anywhere.
It's so easy to use.
KORY JEFFREY: I'm
sure the Sheets
team would love to hear that.
That's awesome.
It's a big win.
Awesome.
Well, thank you for joining.
And thank you guys for joining.
We're live on location at
Founder World in San Francisco.
[MUSIC PLAYING]